Of course, if you can simply use less memory,
that's great. But of course, your goal is to
minimize the dynamic object allocation and de-allocation. Freeing up
those dynamic objects is what the garbage collector is cleaning
up after. So you really want to try to
minimize dynamic object allocation. One way to that of
course, is to manage your own static object pools,
implement your own memory management. For example, you can allocate
an array of objects and hang on to that
whole array and just swap out which ones of those
you're actually using. Of course you need to be
sure that you're not actually allocating more than you need.
But the key to reducing the impact of garbage collection lies in eliminating
excessive object churn, not just memory size. Finally of course, you need to
test your code very carefully for memory leaks. Since memory is so constrained,
it's doubly important that you don't leak memory. And you
don't want to keep increasing your static memory pool. There
are whole books and discussions on best practices to avoid
memory leaks, so we won't go into this in depth here.